let's do some audience questions first
one today is from Chrissy hey guys
what's better McDonald's Burger King or
Wendy's or what about Subway we might be
like the worst people yet to answer this
question Pat it's been 15 years since
I've been to any of those places you
know I mean that these places are not
really vegan Haven no kind no I mean
sometimes they'll go to McDonald's for
their coffee oh I hope I don't want to
bring up another coffee scandal but yeah
with that exception I don't go there
yeah I mean the kirakira gate was bad
enough I think the last thing we need is
a McDonald's coffee scandal listen I to
go to these places when I was younger
but I don't anymore I just think it's
it's all bad I you know knowing very
little about how they've changed since
like I think if I went into a Burger
King I'd have no idea what's going on in
there but from what I recall
Burger King fries were always a disaster
when these chicken nuggets
I remember being the best Subway's bread
had very strange chemicals in it which I
think they've gotten rid of yeah I mean
I know Arby's was kind of a train wreck
I used to go there as well I don't even
go to Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts at this
point I know that those aren't fast-food
in the same sense they're more like you
know corporate cafes or whatever but if
I had to go back to one of them
I remember towards the end of my
fast-food phase again this was like 15
years ago at this point maybe even more
like 16 16 years ago I don't know the
last time I've been to any of these
places
I liked Wendy's the best right and of
course you know these things are cheap
calories too and I think that's a big
reason why people go there all I always
remember other places it's not always as
cheap as some people think
dependent depending on what I'm getting
but yes it is relatively inexpensive in
terms of prepared food I think it's
relatively inexpensive yeah I remember
always going to McDonald's because I
just thought that the other fast-food
burger type joints for a second rate
compared to because that right yeah was
that I feel like a lot of times it's
like within families like I have a
friend whose family always went to
Burger King instead of McDonald's and
they had this idea that Burger King was
way better I couldn't honestly tell you
if there's any appreciable difference
like if you say
compare the hamburgers at these places
when it comes to you know the crappiness
of the ingredients or whatever I really
don't know if there's a difference it
could even be in terms of the fact that
I think there are more McDonald's and
they're just so ubiquitous and that you
know it's one of those kind of biases
but aside from fast-food joints like
that I think yeah I'll sometimes go to
Subway I'll get a veggie Delite on white
for example you will or I'll go to the
burger of the burrito joints as well so
like Chipotle Chipotle yes Chipotle I
don't go to I famously went to the one
on northwestern Connecticut Avenue
Northwest in Washington DC when I was
walking with my roller board suitcase
towards the whatever I think it's the
the Hilton that's up there or whatever
hotel it was that a conference I was
going to was taking place in and after
the constant salmonella listeria I don't
know what it is and my my preference for
supporting local burrito joints where
there are so many of I've been to
Chipotle twice and that's it and I don't
even think the prices are different I
think Chipotle the prices are it's not
even really like a financial thing
people say well I go to Chipotle because
it's cheaper there's usually a local
Mexican place in most urban areas that
it is is inexpensive as Chipotle people
are just comfortable with what they know
but when it comes to Chipotle that only
ranks third on my burrito hierarchy oh I
put the loco and Moe's Southwest Grill
ahead of Chipotle Oh as far as chain
burrito places yes I see what you're
saying I see what you're saying also
keep the joints do you have any
preference I don't go to any fast food
Pizza I mean dot the last time I had
Domino's this is a tell a sanitized
version of the story but on the set I
remember it because it was the day
before a big New Year's Eve party I went
to and I was not feeling well at the
party related to my experience I the
last time I ever ate at Domino's Pizza
was December 30th of 1999 okay Pat was
in diapers at the time and first no
December 30th they were the day before
New Year's gotcha
and I went to Domino's and became became
quite ill as a result of the food that I
had there and as a result the December
31st was not the most fun for me yes see
you always talk about
your highschool job at Circuit City
right correct my high school job was at
Domino's Pizza I'm admitting to that I
was there for about 10 months and I
couldn't even be a delivery driver
because it wasn't old enough right and I
made the pizza who would trust me in
making a pizza that's crazy yeah but you
know the good news is there's no more
coffee scandals because you've just
completely outdone it by saying you used
to make the pizzas at Domino's so I you
don't have to worry about any more
coffee scandals but I was underage at
the time so I think I can get a pass
with that when I was an illegal adult
yeah even better yeah anyway so I don't
know Christie hopefully I provided
something of value to you but now I'm
not exactly the right person for this
for this type of question but people
feel very strongly about it and also oh
yes looking at this
we've got friendlies which is ours
friendlies national because I know it
started in Wilbraham Massachusetts or
somewhere around there I couldn't tell
you yeah there are very few of them now
right yet a lot of them have closed down
I've never been to Popeyes Chicken and
biscuits which is mentioned here I don't
know that I've ever been to Hardee's how
are you think Carl's jr. are the same
but the name is different depending on
where you are in the country okay and I
think I went to Sonic when I was in
California a long time ago KFC I
actually did kind of used to like Canada
you know interestingly KFC is the place
I've been to most recently I think maybe
nine years ago I went to a KFC or eight
years ago and all these others it's been
you know closing it on two decades I
like Sonic for the experience because
you go into this little drive up window
type right right and the waitresses will
come out on rollerskates when you not
like that yeah I love that Pat would go
just just for that really the early days
I don't know